the police have learned how to see the
future experts at the University of
Chicago have created an artificial
intelligence which is able to predict
crimes a week before they happen the
21st century RoboCop was taught using
crime data in Chicago from 2014 to 2016.
the algorithm created a second digital
City divided it into regions and
analyzed each of them to reveal possible
Trends and patterns the algorithm was
then put into action and tested in eight
cities across the U.S and the results
are staggering the algorithm is able to
indicate the time and area of the city
where the crime will occur within a week
to an accuracy of 90 the margin of error
is plus or minus a day this means the
police are able to decide where it is
better to concentrate Manpower on a
certain day the algorithm will continue
to develop and become more complex until
the identity of the future criminal is
revealed that police do not plan to
punish for uncompleted crimes at least
for now subscribe to Samsung here you
can find all the interesting things from
the world of the online jungle